in this video I'm going to be explaining
what the setup costs are to bring your
first HMO property and also what the
ongoing management maintenance costs
look like and how much profit you can be
expected to have at the end of every
single month my name is Samuel Letts and
I am the author of the best-selling
Amazon book by low rent hi how much do
you need to buy an HMO property well of
course it can vary massively it can go
from very high to very very low you can
buy properties without using any money
at all using things like Lease Option
agreements raising finance doing a joint
venture but in this video I'm going to
be explaining what the typical costs
would be for a traditional HMO property
that you bought with your own money so
firstly how much do you need to get
started to put into the deal we're going
to work on the basis of a 25% deposit
you can do it for less but then your
interest rates will be higher so 25%
deposit typically our HMOs are around
about a hundred thousand pounds as a
starting point for a four-bed HMO that
will be 25 thousand pounds straight away
for your deposit so if you haven't got
twenty five thousand pounds you might
need to think creatively on top of your
deposit you've also got two legal fees
now this can vary but your solicitor
fees your standard UTV's it can just
really vary but it shouldn't be more
than a few thousand pounds you're also
going to need refurb costs now we don't
buy properties that need a big refurb we
don't pop on sweets in all the rooms
what we do instead is we furnish them
and make them look amazing that way and
we buy properties that are already in
really good condition
what does it cost to furnish your
property and get a HMO ready well you're
gonna need probably fire doors smoke
alarms and furniture and maybe a lick of
paint and you can typically budget for
that around about 7,000 pounds which
brings us to 32,000 pounds plus legal
fees so whatever age how much will it
cost
I'd say about 35
and pounds as a good starting point next
question how much return you're going to
get back you invest in thirty five
thousand pounds what are you going to
get back well let me say one thing to
start with if you put thirty five
thousand pounds in the bank your return
would be next to nothing and your money
would be shrinking if you put it into a
normal house you might get around ten to
fifteen percent return on investment the
way that we do things we'll have to get
at least 20 percent but usually closer
to the thirty percent return on
investments what's the breakdown of that
and what does that look like what your
rent is going to be on average and it
will vary from house the house but a
good starting point will be three
hundred and fifty pounds per month per
room which will leave you with a total
monthly rent of fourteen hundred pounds
of that fourteen hundred pounds you are
going to have expenses it's not more
yours to keep because of course you're
going to have to pay the mortgage
payments which might be around about 200
pounds a month you're going to have to
pay the bills which is gas electric
broadband council tax water and that on
a four bedroom HMO typically comes down
to around about three hundred pounds a
month and finally you're going to have
to pay somebody to manage the property
find you tenants and take complete
responsibility in control of the
property you can do this yourself but
that's a lot of hard work so I would
recommend using a property manager we
can recommend people to you in fact
whenever we pass a house on we always
make sure we have a Power Team behind up
so how much will that cost we pay twelve
percent of the rent which will be one
hundred and six
pounds Perman however you've gotta round
up because they will also charge you
finders fees referencing fees for the
tenants so we say about 200 pounds a
month we'll have to go towards the
management company let's bring this all
together management company 200 pounds
mortgage payments probably about 200
pounds nails 300 pounds which together
brings a total of 700 pounds profit and
settlement pounds
expenses which is heart the rent is
going to you half the rent is going to
expenses and that is our rule of thumb
whenever you're buying hmm
it's a 5 bit or a 6 then the rents a lot
more the rent might be 2,000 pounds a
month but we will always say half of
that expect to go towards expenses let's
do the math 700 pounds a month is 8400
pounds per year you invested 35,000
pounds that will bring you a grand total
investment of 24 percent per annum which
means that after four years you've got
your money completely back and you've
got your equity trapped in the property
and of course you've got your capital
appreciation as well I always recommend
you in HMOs alongside the lease option
agreements and no money down deals
recycle your rent reinvest it and be
creative and secure properties with no
non if you do these two together there's
no reason why anybody couldn't be
financially independent within 12 months
or less if you found this video helpful
and you want to know more about HMOs and
get to see exactly how we do things
subscribe to this channel and also don't
forget to get a copy of this book in the
link below you'll be able to get this
for
free so enjoy hopefully soon and god
bless you